hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doom eternal we are
just getting into the thick of it
we are stir my goodness gracious I
didn't know that you would start
screaming at me as soon as I got in here
but I appreciate the send o yes please
oh well that was risky don't know I did
that I'm sorry what the betrayers life
signal boo-boo I'm sorry
[Music]
I told you all to leave me here I am
where I belong
saving your people will not bring you
peace only make the burden you carry
worse
and now you seek to defy the carmaker
herself it is your peoples time now to
give penance just as it was mine
hear me Slayer with his hardest laid to
rest in his soul will be the peace and
so will mine
it is your people's turn to pay penance
the betrayer okay let me piece this
together hang on a second
this feels extremely important what we
just encountered and whoever this was uh
here we go this is this hopefully
this'll give some idea
okay the betrayer here we go after years
of prolonged war against the demonic
threat invading their world argent de
noir launched an offensive strike across
dimensions sending their greatest
warriors into the heart of Hell itself
despite their training and the
preparedness their honor was undone by
deceit betrayal at the highest levels of
command left argent de Norse bravest
soul warriors cut off and scattered in
the hellscape but of these last
remaining Knights sentinels only one
remained in Hell by choice betrayer of
the argenta it was commander Valen who
relinquished the keys to the elemental
suppo Corrine returned for his son's
resurrection haunted by demonic visions
the image of his sons tortured existence
plagued him without relent the whispers
of demons pushing them towards madness
in a moment of weakness he fell prey to
the demons trickery sealing the fate of
Argentina and dooming the Kingdom to
which he swore a lifelong oath to
protect Valen chose exile in the hell
scape for his sacrilege now everyone
hold on just a hot second here it was of
my belief that the doom Slayer his
backstory was that he was his son and
that led to the destruction of his
people interesting so this is saying
it's not my character me this dude that
did the betray and also what he just
said okay if he what he just said he's
suggesting that the do Slayers people is
different from the not doom Slayer
people so who is me I'm gonna have to
let that process that's got a marinade
that's that's a that's a lot of that's a
lot of stuff to process let me let me
clear through this let that marinate a
little bit in my brain and we'll just
see how this do in a bit oh [ __ ] I
forgot
because thanks Vega thanks babe you're
always good for me
appreciate you could get another one up
that's what I could get it so if I let
this fall you incus nice sick awesome
where's this Mario hey time oh look wait
what's this
oh I thought there was a there was like
a green glowy I thought that meant it
was so well I've got egg on my face
it's the propulsion system it's not a
special it's that that I was like a 1 up
or something oh oh I smell a battle
all right who we got here
no no no no ha ha gimme you and give me
you give me up nice yes yes I'm the
dresser ever was whoa hey bud you came
out of nowhere
look I don't lie don't want to mess and
you're gonna splode you're gonna splode
you're gonna load missiles incoming I
don't like the sound of that
whoo boy okay let me get out of here get
blood punches active so let me you and
you that was good that helped hurt that
guy a good bit you yeah the main thing
is like just situational awareness I
think so long as I'm able to stay on the
move
stay stay fresh stay hostile and use the
environment to my advantage I think I'm
gonna be generally okay well this guy's
pissed well he is not happy
oh my blood punched his his thing right
off his head his dick this his giant gun
dick I did that and I actually regret
what I just said because that sounds
really weird and horrible nope okay we
got the whip oh I had a quad damage oh
god I had a quad damage right there I'm
an idiot well that's okay it just means
I'm good enough to do without it
okay so I need to get to those one other
lace here wait wait there wait where
here that I think is the last thing in
the bar here and I didn't think that I
was gonna be very completionist about
this but the fact that I'm one away I'm
totally fine with going back for because
this is just fun shockingly the game's
fun so yeah I would love to play more
the more you this game can give me the
happier I you know I am because the game
is fun it's right there okay I don't
know what it is I think it might be like
one of those special orb things that I
rip the guts out and I eat I can only
assume that's what I'm doing with it
after I'm done
be wasteful not to here here no no no
this is where it was oh so I gotta like
drop when I get close to here here is
this it yes yes yes yes I saw it I saw
it I saw it there it is okay alright
bring it on baby let's peace
once be swirled you dudes hey long time
no see all right I did it well they're
dead now
well guess I'll go back to the Isle of
torment I got all of those so that means
I must have weapon points which I guess
I use oh no I'm done dude
I almost got everything dude that's
awesome crazy oh I was just missing the
toys damn dude I love old up whatever
that means yeah I guess I still don't
know what the leveling system does for
me
but I feel good okay so with the lore
difference I always thought that was the
Slayers
backstory and I did love the simplicity
of it like he was on an eternal quest
for vengeance to pay penance for his
mistake and I thought that was very
strong yet very simplistic motivation
for it but this is saying it's not the
case so who is the doom Slayer who is
the doom Slayer and what is their
motivation you know what I mean I'm
actually kind of curious about that
because okay am I going to kill someone
okay cool
whatever that means so yeah what I'm
saying is like that was very strong very
simple motivation I'm only hoping that
they changed that because that is a
change right I'm pretty sure that was
pretty set in stone and that was one of
the things I loved about the Slayer is
just like he's just perpetually pissed
off he will never give a demon a second
chance because he knows the punishment
for trying to trust them like that's
just who he is and that's what he does
period there is no exception when it
comes to demons and peace both cursed
and empowered by being the Slayer but
you know it's it's a punishment at the
same time ooh I thought this was locked
on insert Sentinel batteries into
sockets within the fortress of doom to
unlock of items in power-ups okay okay
[Music]
oh yes I want it so badly
that's the original gonna - that's gonna
be my ass that's gonna be America's ass
that is the original doom armor oh I
want it I've never wanted anything more
in my life oh I want it
how many Sentinel batteries do I have do
I have any I thought I picked up a bunch
but I use them to the blast giant lasers
like an idiot kind of idiot am I the
best the worst kind the best kind the
worst kind whoa oh I want it is that the
unmake err set the UNMIK err set the
unmake or is that my own maker will
where am I going
oh I'm in space can I jump off yes again
oh let me drift in - oh yeah I don't
know where I'm going what is that funky
funky funky okay so I need seminal
batteries for that I'm guessing I need
seminal batteries for just about
everything holy crap look at this place
yeah drift damn look at this place
what are these panels for some kind of
mario 64 level jump into paintings
mechanic be pretty neat
oh hi fortress of doom the fortress of
doom is a command station used by the
Sentinels for military operations yes
are dating suggest the structure was
built during the reign of King Bannick
and spectral analysis of the seminal
energy signature used to power the
various systems confirms this theory
while the rock and metal structure of
the vessel is undoubtedly Argenta design
the castle subsystems navigation
gravitational centrifuge life-support
are of maker origin suggesting a design
collaboration between the two species
propulsion is notably absent as it is
not required the fortress manipulates
space through an unknown process
involving sentinel energy however there
is no indication that any of these
systems are designed for maker use the
access ways control panels and living
quarters have all been designed for
argenta dimensions so it can be assumed
that the massive structure was made
exclusively for our gentle warfare
likely as a flag station of the night
sentinels military forces we have
records of the night sentinels visiting
many inhabited planets in their local
quadrant the extent of their empires
still being researched and this fortress
is likely a remnant of what was once in
much larger fleet ok nice so that's just
a weapon rack so a big wheel grinding
nunchucks ok collectibles a an exclusive
look at the BFG 10,000 it's finally here
and yes it's over 9000
[Laughter]
oh that's from the the other game that's
the armor from the original oh
interesting ooh very Iron Men oh there's
the original helmet hey I've got that
helmet right here there she is oh no
this is the one from this game that's
must be the old one that one had a
bigger visor so you know you could see
better but this one no this one this is
still pretty cool
so the Slayer plays the Slayer slays is
what you're saying
the Slayer skates Slayer shreds doom oh
[Applause]
I'm guessing you would be able to play
doom on doom doom in Doom oh please tell
me I get to pilot one of those at some
point in the game
please yet whoa isn't that the thing
from Doom 3 isn't that the very
important very deadly cube the only
thing that can kill super demons isn't
that isn't that the thing it's just a
desk desecration rip and tear mix
shotgun portraits collectibles best
kills comp glory kill list Phase II
picks who's Daisy this is this is fun
exam the harmful effects of demonizing
the mortally challenged why the Slayer
owes the demon community apology wow you
guys are so boned when I find you sweet
PC my dude oh no where's my body
oh I haven't gotten any toys goddammit I
haven't gotten any I haven't gotten any
at all hey bud punch oh wait is it here
guys I have something to tell you the
developers of this game they gave me a
little bit of a surprise I I know what
it is I think it's here but I haven't
seen it in person yet it's one of these
books has an Easter Egg there how to
comb your mustache Clifton M Fishbach
that's my dad's name and my dad had a
killer mustache here's a picture of my
dad with a mustache um they put this in
because I said to them how important
this game was to me this was one of the
original games that I ever played and it
always has a special place in my heart
and so they said they were gonna do
something special and now that's gonna
be in the game forever and it's the
biggest book here - that's really nice
that's that's really nice that is really
sweet and you know it's such a small it
may seem like such a small thing but my
dad's name is like in this game forever
now and anyone can see it and anyone can
find it and anyone can learn how to comb
your moustache that's really cool so
thank you
did the developers the game and the
people to put this in here just thank
you
I'm loving the game so far I can't wait
okay all right I'm gonna get outta here
I want to keep playing the game I could
spend a while out here just looking at
stuff holy crap look at that but just
like just understand that means a lot he
really does
and I really appreciate it so thank you
very much all right moving on we're
gonna get back into the game but I'm
glad I was able to find that so there's
a big place here but obviously I can't
do jack squat until I get more Sentinel
batteries so until I get more Sentinel
batteries I'm just gonna keep killing
demons and hope that they COFF up some
Sentinel batteries because they're just
gonna put them in my hand ooh hi how are
you
oh yeah the freeze bomb that's gonna be
useful okay freezes any demon hit by the
blast I need to swap between grenades
with G which is gonna be the tough thing
okay sounds old oh that's what I got
that's the music all right cool that's
the music all right cool cool cool cool
what am i doing take the lift down to
the prison why we have a prison whoa
whoa hi all right time to go visit the
prisoners like oh mama oh mama
whoa mama Dan how do they ever lose any
fight when they had these giant robots I
mean I'm the doom Slayer I can kill
anything by myself but how did anyone
lose with those the rivet work the Ripa
the repertory of the Ripa tour iam the
Ripa torreón the Ripa torreón the Ripa
dorium demon prison allows you to
practice fighting demons without dying
or permanently losing inventory items
such as ammo or extra lives new
encounter unlocks
so I get I just get to kill things is
what you're saying
what you're saying is this is just for
killing things
damn alright okay alright interesting Oh
BFG Division plays in here oh my god
cool alright that's enough of that
that's enough of that that's enough of
that okay all right okay all right cool
a crier of crater stood point hello oh
oh hi
ghosts all right I seen you before
oh this oh okay oh okay okay okay okay
how many pretty suits I got one okay
reveals all progression items in the
dossier rad suit faster ledge I'm
guessing this is nice it's the only
thing I can buy but that'll help me find
extra stuff faster I guess cool I've
also got weapon points and wonder if I
can do anything about that it's still on
your load speed yeah I love the sticky
bombs like it's just it's so sweet okay
cool thanks but thanks Badou cheers
Cheers okay my mission is to infiltrate
the cult of space I'm pretty sure by
infiltrating mean kicking the door so
hard that their grandfathers feel it all
right where do I turn where do i dial
the where do I pull what do I punch to
make this matter
paunch I'm so strong that qualifies as a
punch everybody just Ark broadcast
broadcast log please avoid all contact
with the doom guy at this time that's
just I'm busy I got [ __ ] to do so I'm
gonna go do that [ __ ] don't worry about
it don't worry about nothing I got this
okay where am I going cultist base with
the celestial locator now in your
possession you're able to pinpoint the
locations of the remaining health
priests dig run a crew leader of the USC
division responsible first invasion has
been located at the coldest Arctic base
infiltrate the encampment and neutralize
will knock why now with the leaf blower
whatever
everyone ignore the leaf blower just pay
attention to my sultry voice I swear
they leave blow there every day why
there's
there cannot be that many leaves it is
impossible all right what do we have
here cult this base led by the elusive
hell's priest degra knock the cultists
are afraid remote the good leaf floors
are a plague ranek worked briefly with
Olivia Pierce of the Mars facility
before departing to earth with orders to
prepare the groundwork for the imminent
hel invasion interesting so that was
Olivia who turned into the fighter
mastermind rumored a personal knowledge
of the doom Slayer ooh
suggesting a shared history between the
two uses growing inflows to advance a
consumption of earth built over the
ruins of the ancient argenta oh wait
found it to be popular with powerful
Pramila beasts it's covered earth
millennia ago
whoa stop built over the ruins of an
ancient argenta settlement occultist
facility has been designed as both a
gothic monument to the ancient
architecture and state-of-the-art
science facility tablets and memory
banks founded the settlement indicate
that the order of the dag discovered
earth millennia ago and found it to be
popular with powerful primeval beasts
then indie creatures
AGGA Dawn's due to their similarity to
the mythic cyclopean giant from the
Argent indoors past the AG kadian what
kind wide was on earth the dinos are you
talking about the dinos mission
challenges are optional tres Academy
complete at any point okay challenges
whole crystal armor drain okay that's
easy
well that's really easy hop hop
got it oh hi how you doing
hmm that doesn't seem good okay I like
the background it's a nice change of
pace from just normal hellscape I'm
guessing these are bad to touch I'm just
guessing ow
yep bad touch okay there was a secret
somewhere yeah what are you oh oh you're
cute oh wait no that was cute oh hello
oh I suppose that would have been easier
to get to the secret but I just jumped
around it anyway hello oh hi oh I'm so
getting my flaming belt reward yeah and
then oh no no that's not what I want
grenade oh hi
oh man you got blown oh [ __ ]
there we go boink and you're done oh no
oh no and these guys suck guys are
garbage you guys need to get good what
what are you supposed to be ah [ __ ] I
missed what is that what is that oh god
damn it
oh god damn it really really this is how
I die oh I can't even touch it anyway
okay I don't know what that is all about
the I I'm dying
apparently alright sure yeah okay this
sure Oh what the hell oh I killed it
what is that what is that what is that
cool
are we on earth this doesn't feel like
Earth I'm just gonna say that straight
up this don't don't feel like Earth Oh
found a secret baby I don't know what I
did but it was probably awesome and I
congratulate myself on my awesomeness
what is that what is happening where did
that open up I don't even know where
that opened up a secret Hey I spy with
my little eye a central battery that's
gonna go boom was it in here really Leif
oh man I'm having a moment I'm enjoying
okay hey cut it
wow that's that's a little unnecessary
alright goodbye
see you around bud stop Oh
I said stop you're a little tougher than
the average wait a minute this place is
full of traps I love it wait but I still
don't know where the hell that elevator
opened up it I opened up an elevator
somewhere and I still don't know where
it was how am I where is the elevator
how am I supposed to know where that was
did I miss it did I pass it there's
something behind there but I don't think
I could make it over there well it's
over there there's a loop-de-loop why
would there be a loop-de-loop all the
way over there hmm
guys I'm trying my best there must've
been something over here nope I have no
idea where that opened here here or here
we go what do we got here oh yes yes yes
Sentinel battery baby okay there we go
got it all right now we can move forward
with reckless abandon now I can try to
do this thing oh no it doesn't even want
you to try that never mind
I didn't bother that wasn't me I didn't
do it
what's goofy okay water
what are you doing what are they doing I
don't know what they're doing okay we'll
be do be tie Babel we yeah I don't think
somehow I don't think that's gonna be
much of a problem for me yes
considering how I've killed hell for
about a thousand years in a row I don't
think you're gonna have much of anything
to say about me surviving your head's
gone buddy yeah it's not gonna oh wait
yep
bunk
Oh little stumpy can't do much when you
got your guns all blowed alright ok
interesting thanks for telling me a
manky missile is on the way Oh No hey
where'd you guys come from what are you
doing hey you're so silly so silly
yes so silly oh whoa Oh what the hell
happened to me something something
zapped up the ground I didn't know what
that was right you're dead and you're
dead
oh another one you say aah
stop it
okay so it's being a little well my
goodness that's how we're gonna be huh
oh my god there's two oh [ __ ] oh god I
need ah [ __ ] I needed that okay I didn't
have it
[ __ ] I'm wasting all my lives okay you
can still get them with these that's
good to know
Oh
big guy big guy fall damn I keep wasting
my my hoozy what's it I don't mean to do
that hey thank you thank you big guy
thank you Prater soup sorry that was an
accident didn't mean to do that
all right cool all right
easy peasy form easy hi
and these guys don't like each other I
know why they don't get along they
should hey whoa hey bud baguette you
know I did not
damn you can't just shoot that thing can
you okay freeze up
oink
oh god I keep forgetting what the
buttons are there's a lot of buttons
that they've added on to my repertoire
that I got to remember I just need to do
them and I keep instinctively trying to
reload after certain kills that's not a
thing in this game that is reloading
yeah kind of the opposite of what
everything is about in this game also I
should take advantage of the
environmental stuff a lot more also
what's over here
secret secrets which way do you want me
to go oh you want me to go that way huh
well then that means there's a secret
over here hi I'm here now it was a hey
wow that looks skooshy okay so is there
whoa okay what's the point of being up
here that's the point of being up here
oh I got the cultist key baby okay so I
bet I can get down here I don't know why
I want to get down here but I bet I can
nope the answer is I don't want to get
down there I've discovered it I figured
it out guys guys don't you worry Oh mark
your moves got this all in the bag
I know exactly what I'm doing oh boy
oh yeah blow blow blow blow blow come on
blow before I blow blow blow blow yes
that was not worth it not worth it at
all whoo yes get shrekt ee got ease the
button girl really losing it on the the
slew of buttons that I have to remember
all right call this key all right did I
get everything I needed what's that down
there hey what's going on there down
there buckaroo apparently I went there a
little bit whatever I'll figure it out
later
plasma rifle can quickly destroy energy
shields which triggers a damaging
explosion that's very good to know
okay shields boom boom got it okay I'm
gonna take advantage of all the blowies
in this area who needs salve tactics
you've got clear shots all around here
oh here what am I going for here oh yes
very close
oh no I didn't let my thing charge god
damn it
oh is that what I think it is oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
please tell me I can actually hit
something oh my god
oh my god you're a pile of wet goo I'm
not doing this right but Wow
boy that felt good my goodness I'm not
doing this right at all oh god I can't
remember the buttons at all oh they're
all of my extra lifes are going right
now okay stop being an idiot holy crap
whoa see just like that oh man I go in
there for two seconds and I'm just done
okay whoa okay so the answer is stop
trying to play up close and personal
with the mangaboos they don't joke
around they are no joke period all right
what am I looking for who it is
something at the booth now how do I get
up a booth how do I get up there how do
I do it
oh I see whoo nailed it
I'm the best oh [ __ ] okay how about I do
the death one that seems like a good
move because that way it'll save my 1ups
and I'll get a nice slow-motion boost
that'd be pretty good I don't see
anything wrong that could go with that
okay why am i up here other than that I
feel really tall which is cool oh yeah
that would have been useful all right so
that's everything there there's still
something bad going on there there's
something down there
there's something over here here
look at that do oh well that would have
made going up there easier but
apparently I didn't need it all right
whatever do a little too late where am I
going
Oh back up and now I'm dumb guys turns
out very dumb very dumb incredibly dumb
actually Oh God hello goodbye I'm dead
oh [ __ ] there we go make those guys yeah
that's the death save that I needed okay
I don't heal at all which is very
important to keep in mind
whoo ow ow ow oh you hurt real good hold
still and kaboom done there we go
I don't know what the gurgle gurgles
we're all about but I got through that
okay man a lot of this is just gonna be
learning like the behaviors of these
enemies and trying to figure out what's
the priority which I'm guessing is the
point of the game that that sounds like
the point our rocket launcher remote
detonate lock on target whoa three at
once oh let's do the three at once if I
need to take care of a big dude that's
gonna do the job
thanks Vega you you a doll you a doll
baby you a doll you sweetie you real
sweetie
okay so there's something whoa hello
Hey
I guess I could have blown that up too
I'm still not tuned in to the
environmental clues but I'll get there
eventually because I'm smart I'm big
brain and you guys know it and you guys
all agree with it and if you don't agree
that I'm gonna cry if there's a secret
somewhere here somewhere here yeah that
what is that what I'm gonna look at it
oh that's what I'm looking at how do I
get in there my there's got to be a way
to open that gate so if there's got to
be a switch somewhere that I can utilize
but I don't see where it is and I'm not
gonna waste too much time thinking about
it so off we go into the wild blue
yonder oh boy you didn't deserve that
because it missed you
whoof oh my God look at the spine Oh
Mamba Jamba okay I'm just gonna try to
get some distance try to control the
battlefield a bit more until I can get
you where I want you
well you guys are gonna be fodder where
are you at revi Jesus oh you got ya you
gots give me this please
I see armor okay I'm gonna freeze good
I'm gonna get your corn whether you like
it or not and you're dead
whoa what's spawning I didn't know
you're gonna tether tether tether go go
go missiles incoming it didn't want to
either kaboom
there we go that's how I do see ya oh no
oh no that's not ideal that's not ideal
either you hate to see it ya hate to see
you just ya hate to see it all right I'm
gonna blood punch you I'm gonna blast
you gonna blow you away with this whoo
something just keeps hitting me for like
50 at a time yeah I don't know what that
does something it's be hard like really
hard and it's just because I have no
shield so I got our I got to figure out
a way to get shields back up in a hurry
okay that's down so I got to get like
the threats down so I got to get like
the weak points engaged
no not today
where am I I didn't know where I went
but I went into the abyss to hear you
let's get some distance
switch up yeah you you freeze no not
quite
yeah there we go Rockets Rockets baby
all day that's good
okay blood punch stat get that you stop
being you done get this armor oh yes
it's like oh you you you you oh [ __ ] oh
god damn it oh there goes my chance okay
rocket launch
boink locked go
boom
boom boom all right now I'm getting into
a good flow oh is that is that all of
them oh no oh no was that is that all
now I'm starting to get it
let's keep going yeah thanks for the
seminal battery mm something I can punch
fault
whoa hey I'm here now I'm bad I'm gonna
waste that real soon yeah that's not
gonna happen
uh-huh yeah about that yeah I don't know
what place you're gonna get when you're
a bunch of giblets on the bottom of the
floor all right so what is this place
kind of an arena type deal am I about to
fight a big baddie I hope so I love
fighting big baddies oh yes please thank
you well thanks for the powerup and
thanks for all the people that I got to
destroy very helpful very helpful in my
quest to come kill you so if you could
just lay down a relic from my past doink
doink doink doink
a relic from my past you say a relic
from my past going oh you are not my
super shotgun where's my super shotgun I
was told that my super shotgun was
nearby I was told this a relic from my
past I'm wondering I really am wondering
whoa that was a sudden drop
cool what's your objective here down a
goo I'm wondering if this doom guy does
tie-in cue balls and even shoot them
sends them flying when they collide with
other demons right oh yeah I guess I
should pay attention to where they are
[Music]
oh not today oh that's not what I want
nope get go get the goddamn thing there
we go that's how you deal with them
that's how you do the business whoa whoa
well they just they just destroy me so
quickly
holy crap okay four no no no no there we
go killing him give me your health we're
doing the slo-mo style
there we go
you think I got that rune or else this
would be a lot more difficult I'm
beginning to think like I got cue bald
myself which seems likely at this point
all right cool glad you guys recognize
that I'm superior and that you ended
your trap that I was pretty much stuck
in forever thanks for letting me out
though that was nice
all right how do I get there I just
don't know but there is the crystal
there that I want real bad oh I see I
see I see I got actually go open it and
I gotta get this oh thank you thank you
for that thank you very much for that ah
I fell in that I didn't think I was not
paying attention whoo ah ah there we go
doing kiss
sweet I'm thinking what I want is the
belt faster belts next because I think I
want to be able to get armor more
regularly I think that's the key to all
this
yeah that's got to be the key and what
what surprise are you gonna have for me
[Music]
hello
easy God give me a challenge where am I
going now I'm headed in kind of the
right direction
weird hello no oh I thought I was being
crushed hi
where am I I really really truly
panicked I thought I was being crushed
to death well that was a heart attack
and a half that I didn't I need all
right buddy
power friend how are you anyway did I
finish my thought from before I wonder
if my character right here is the doom
guy from one of the original games may
not be all of them but I don't know what
did I do
what did I just do oh I did something I
was not paying attention to what that
did that damn it what did that do what
did that do
oh I see okay there's a climb above wall
there how am I supposed to be able to
discern that from like half a glance
there we go that's a bit of a combo okay
but now what oh I see nice
I know I said no I said nah here's my
shot shooting my shot
there we go
okay it's good to bit dicey sometimes
okay do I want to keep going up I'm
guessing yeah
okay and now I've got this yeah we have
it Sentinel battery in my possession I
think that's pretty much everything I
need to do
where am I going now out oh I just go
out oh so they didn't release me from my
trap that I was in pretty much forever
and they would have been stupid to just
let me out oh they only let me out when
I was already here so it almost didn't
matter that they let me out
oh my Aleuts are awesome I think that's
one thing that people could always say
about the doom Slayers that his
alley-oops are divine to die for almost
hey buddy are you gonna get exploded
this is gonna kill you I really hope
this kills you
oh yeah crush them or not yes
whoa what the heck I just got turned
into a demon no it's fine
buy anything for the cookies what what
the hell I'm in control of a revenant
playing as a revenant oh my god they
were they're not gonna bother me because
I'm just well how would you know how do
you know
Oh weird Oh
whoa okay this is almost better than
being the doom Slayer oh this is rad oh
hey
oh my god this is fun this is fun I can
see I know there's ways for other
players to get in your game I'm just not
a hundred percent sure
cool I know this is just a tutorial to
be able to play in other people's games
let me get my super shotgun and I bet
I'm gonna kick this guy's ass oh hey bud
oh hey I got you your shotgun boss boss
I got you your gun and I get to enjoy a
delicious cookie as a reward oh that's
quite good
hey boss here you go
huh yep just kill it [ __ ] shoot it
actually you know you served me well
you're a good boy you're not so bad I'm
on named you Steve this is Steve
everybody this is my pet name Steve and
Steve he's a good boy
we got some guts hanging out Steve
anyway I gotta get going Dave I'll see
you around
hi bud features a meat hook Maude oh
yeah oh oh I missed ya
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah this is my jam I
don't know if I'm gonna be using any
other game from now on or gone any other
game and I switched to a gun immediately
like a like an [ __ ]
what okay I'm just disappeared I want to
see if I can get ah nah you need to get
that one but there's fine more meat hook
who's gonna be this [ __ ] from now on and
forever oh that's a lot of shotgun
shells hey ba whoa bad one that was a
bad one
I am already low on health
oh my god I forgot about the auto
shotgun oh that was pretty cool
I forgot about that whoa that's a
mistake that's not right oh that's not
right sorry last one
go ahead hey buds Oh God Oh II Gatz Oh
God
Oh No I keep making the mistake of not
knowing which one does what oh no the
last one again ah I'm just too
distracted by these cookies come on you
come on you no no no no okay if I could
just hit okay if I could just there we
go there you go now you're dead okay
good good good
all good okay oh there is jumpies all
this time and I did not know oh there's
a secret
Oh way
hey iddqd that's the invincibility cheat
code I know that one yeah priests must
survive gotcha big big understand on
that one chief
all right doing good doing good getting
better doing good loving my super
shotgun loving it really really loving
it oh hey this looks official this looks
like the kind of place that someone
wouldn't want to die in and yet they're
gonna anyway that looks cool whatever
that is that's neat
that's really neat anyway I'm gonna blow
it up now I'm gonna blow up all your
stuff I'm just gonna blow up literally
everything you've ever cared or loved
about actually I'm gonna sit around and
I'm gonna twiddle my dick because I
don't know exactly where I'm supposed to
oh here we go
I just had to find the one thing that
had an entrance in it oh yeah
oh yeah and tada just like VAW
we've got it y'all oh wow that's not
ideal I'm here anyway
all right cool good glad I got this gun
Boosh
all right hey bud how you doing hey good
to see you good see you it's how you
babe
family good all dead great who's the
betrayers fault you know for the longest
time I thought that was my fault
like I was like that's my bad but turns
out not my fault at all I don't even
need to worry about it I've got so many
suit things ooh
immune to damage from barrel explosions
that's not a bad idea
cuz I probably blow myself up more than
anything that's probably that's not a
bad idea okay okay okay okay not bad not
bad oh [ __ ]
apparently this is uh okay I I messed
that up real bad Hey all right where we
going what are we doing here what are we
doing where we go whoa hey now that's
mean there's got to be like secrets here
oh yeah directly above me okay so
through here but how does one get oh I
see it I see it I see it boom so what
are these oh that's right they
regenerate I forgot about that the thing
I literally just got I completely forgot
about kaboom kaboom I'm immune to those
you know you're frozen I think oh god oh
god oh god no not what I wanted
come on Oh God Oh God
let me oh no no God oh god I keep I keep
being dumb whoa you come in so follow my
god that's actually tough okay suddenly
I don't know if like I suddenly forgot
how to play with things suddenly got
tough Jesus Christ Jesus Christ oh my
god oh my god
just Todd I know this one oh my god this
got incredibly more difficult out of
nowhere
yes there we go okay got it
the the trick was I just had to get out
of that room when I was in that room
it's just a death trap speaking of death
trap fascinating
very interesting oh that didn't do what
I thought it was going to do what did
that just do oh my god oh hi yes please
thank you
bottles oh wow you suck Oh what do we
got here Oh almost near the other place
so there's a secret somewhere here not a
bunch of Secrets that I just haven't
been able to find oh that's definitely a
secret yeah ooh okay so I got that I
just need to get up and out of here oh
you just suck
[Music]
oh I see I see what I need to do
okay got that just need to get here and
then I'm almost to killing a big priest
which is my favorite thing
what two men doing I punch it no dude oh
I get it I think this needs to like be
pushed through this as an amplifier
there we go that's what it is or a
diffuser or a splitter something like
that are you know not really actually no
I don't think you can I'm pretty sure
you don't understand the implications of
what you're asking I actually am
perpetually cursed to never grow tired
my rage only huh whoa hey
okay getting better getting better
getting better just getting smarter
making better choices almost there
almost where hell no no no no not with
you get off the ceiling you [ __ ]
sorry oh you got microwave a stood that
what is that wow that's cool
do I need to punch it in his chest I
sure do and I'm going to woo there's
that key
no no Harper since you're out to get to
that there's the Slayer special oh oh
that looks punchable but not a I'm not
man enough to bunch it who'da thunk
impossible to contemplate the idea and
yet here I go I'm about to give this
thing the punch of its entire existence
I mean it might be dead but it's still
gonna punch the [ __ ] out of it
oh yeah this feels Punchbowl oink oh
it's not what I thought was gonna happen
but I will punch this bad ass in that's
bad ass chest that's how you do it and
that ladies and gentlemen is how you do
it listen there is no need for raucous
applause but I understand that you can't
control yourself I get it you have to
let that [ __ ] out it'll build up inside
you if you don't oh yeah oh yeah this
feels right
so how was I supposed to get that key
hmm probably some wave to go up top and
then you drop down or looks like that's
a climb above wall oh oh wait a minute
oh here oh oh my god
all right I'm ready for another - almost
didn't get that I'm ready for another
challenge baby oh I'm so ready I am so
down for this alright we'll do this
challenge we're finish this level and
then we'll end this episode that sounds
like a good plan unless this takes me 30
minutes to be because I've messed it up
so much but I doubt that I doubt it here
I go pull right into it okay not losing
any oh my god not losing any time to
anything can you get that
okay you give me you okay keeping this
nice and even
okay you okay good
easy enough
okay yeah i'ma get out of here quick
this
oh [ __ ] something rocked me I don't know
what what's hitting me oh god you
oh god you I know what you are huh okay
just trying to get some space yeah you
you're a son of a [ __ ] ain't ya
yep you are you are you are oh god this
is not good
I'm at a loss for what to do Oh God
Oh God where is you no no no no no not
you not you where is something I can do
do that - okay we got some space
hey you yeah you
these are like super imps they're big
imps and they suck no no no no not today
oh not today goddamn it get out of the
way okay I'm getting out of here blowing
that up just to get some if anything was
chasing me oh I can get one of these
twos all right you're getting yes eat
some of that got him okay it's gonna try
to get this yes
nailed that
Oh damnit I hit myself whoa
where is it missed it by that much yes
I love being immune to those barrels I
really do that is awfully nice that is
very very nice to be able to say that I
am just plain old immune Oh perfect for
if they're chasing me down and I need to
get some space oh I love that that is
fantastic
all right big boy time for the final
confrontation what are you gonna do
punch me with your noodle arms yeah I've
been waiting for you to show yourself
because this is pathetic
I'd probably miss some secrets I did but
that's fine I feel good I got all the
demon corruption things done so take the
train to the terrordome
is that the name of this thing the
terrordome cuz that's an awesome name hi
hey bud almost didn't find you what are
you doing hiding in the corner over
there the thing is like it's so
satisfying feeling like I'm getting
better at the game oh that was Trixie
Trixie bastard
but it's so satisfying when I do like
feel like I've accomplished it because I
legitimately am getting better
oh god this does dumb move
whoa whoo are you about her of a rockets
showdown buddy Wow that still hurts me
up close I'm not immune to that one I
don't remember that whoa hey bud where'd
you come from
Wow Oh No
what happened to my rune oh no that man
keepers must have come up behind me when
I didn't notice god damn it still hurts
still hurts nope yeah there we go whoa
whoa what was that got you Wow there's
that thing the same one that got me
before oh no no no no this is not ideal
where is it dude give me a dude there we
go that's dude where's my health where's
my goddamn health there's some goddamn
hell I'm going to cross map from
downtown Oh God hey did they just bathe
you make a silly little mistake in boy
howdy they make you pay for it
okay I need to do dares dude that's dude
all right
Oh got him get out of my way get out of
my way Oh God stop stop stop do not do
not not all this way
there we go this gets tough sometimes
that was tougher than like the event all
right time to kill this dude how bad
could it possibly be
it was probably secret in that area but
I didn't feel like going to look for it
Oh time to go to the terror oh I don't
get to go to the terror dome in this
level oh I got most of the exploration
that's pretty good nice nice nice nice
nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice
nice I missed one crater soup point and
one toy not bad I can't no rewards and
that's fine
it's all good I get it no no I don't get
rewards that's all it is
okay so that'll do it for this episode
of doom eternal I am enjoying the crap
out of this this is so much fun it is
it's like just because I get frustrated
sometimes when I died doesn't mean that
I don't want to keep playing it's it's
the kind of frustration that just makes
you want to keep going that's what's
beautiful about it just it really gives
you this idea that like you just want to
keep rolling with it you want to get
better the gunplay in this game is of a
higher level than I've seen in pretty
much any game I've ever played period it
is ludicrous how involved the FPS
mechanics of this game are they've
turned it into something like an
acrobatic dance of guns it's a ballet of
death as I think some journalists have
said but it's really fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play Doom eternal for yourself
my god go play it it is stupid fun
stupid fun do I get some Slayer demonic
Slayer oh my god oh wow
I don't deserve nyla I like basic I'm
not customizer really I really am NOT
hey Dwight thank you everybody so much
for watching check out more doom that
I've played in the description below in
the playlist listed down there and check
out some of the other games that I
played there's tons of them I've got
over 4,000 videos coming up on 5000
videos now so thanks again subscribe for
more ring the bell if you want to know
when the next episodes going up
and leave it like if you enjoyed the
video thanks everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]